hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2021 american superhero movie called
eternals
the movie begins with the eternals
believing they are from planet olympia
receiving their mission from the
celestials through their leader ayak
also called the prime eternal only she
is able to communicate with irishm one
of the celestials they suit up and get
ready to receive their mission to earth
by boarding the domo their spacecraft
they believe their mission is to
eliminate deviants beings consuming
intelligent life on every planet
they arrive in 5000 bc mesopotamia
evacuating local people from deviant
attacks and befriending them
cersei an eternal being able to
manipulate matter is most attached to
humans and is often followed around by
icarus one of the strongest eternals who
has feelings for her icarus counts as
their best fighter able to fly and shoot
cosmic energy beams from his eyes the
team also has thena a skillful warrior
gilgamesh a powerful but caring being
kingo who can project energy blasts from
his hand druik a mind manipulator and
telepath fastos a genius mind macri a
speedster and sprite an illusionist
after the fight cersei enhances a blade
and gives it to a human child
in the present day the same blade is
displayed on a giant screen in london's
busy intersection as cersei hurries down
to the natural history museum to give
lessons to high school students dane
whitman her current love interest
welcomes her to class
when giving the lecture a big earthquake
happens
at night after hanging out in a pub
cersei sprite and dane are heading home
when they are suddenly attacked by a
deviant they notice that the deviant
knows where they are and are only
attacking them not humans it can also
heal itself like ayoke out of nowhere
icarus appears and forces the deviant to
retreat dane demands an explanation of
cersei's true identity and mission and
she explains how they thought they
eradicated all deviants five centuries
ago and they will not interfere with all
man-made conflicts
they still stay on earth long after the
deviants were eradicated to wait for
their instruction to go home
dane also asked about icarus cersei's
past lover for five thousand years
before he left icarus suggests that they
need to find the others so they head to
ayak turns out ayak is already dead
presumably by a deviant attack
morning they flash back to old times
in 575 bc babylon after defeating the
deviants and evacuating humans ayak
communicated with irishm through the
sphere embedded in her chest
she told her ishm that she feels
something special about this planet but
he reminded her not to become too
attached to humans and only focus on
their mission
fasto showed an advanced design of the
steam engine which he would show to
humans but ayak refused his idea and let
humanity evolve slowly at night they
were having a firework party cersei and
icarus bonded and they confessed their
love for each other
centuries later in the gupta empire they
married
back to the present day cersei is still
mourning ayak's death when suddenly the
sphere inside yak's body moves into
cersei's symbolizing cersei as the prime
eternal
she visualizes seeing a rishen but
quickly regains her composure
sprite and icarus are worried about her
if she is experiencing a psychological
condition known as mod wiry as
experienced by thena back in 1521 a.d
tenochtitlan the eternals were just
defeating the last of the deviants when
they suddenly went rogue and hurt other
eternals
she was healed by a yak erasing her
memories but she begged to have her
memories back
gildamesh supported her even though he
risked having her gone rogue again
druid confronted ayak doubting her
decisions and her rules about them not
interfering with man conflicts he
abruptly left soon after
ayak disbanded the group allowing
everyone to live a life on their own
back to the present day in mumbai the
group meet with king go now a renowned
bollywood star
kingo is always accompanied by his loyal
valet karoon
they go to australia meeting gilgamesh
and thena during a feast cersei still
thinks about her new position as prime
maternal goes outside and tries hard to
communicate with irishm again
she finally succeeds and learns that
their main mission on earth is not to
eradicate deviants but to prepare for
the birth of a celestial named tiamet a
phenomenon called the emergence
to grow it needs a vast amount of energy
from intelligent life
deviants are also rishem's creation but
they defy their true purpose to
eradicate apex predators on every planet
and evolve to become predators
themselves
with them being predators a planet would
never have enough intelligent life for
the emergence of the celestial
cersei is shocked to know that everyone
on earth will die for the emergence and
more shocked when she knows planet
olympia does not exist as eternals are
built and programmed by arisham in a
place called the world forge they have
their memory stored there then are sent
on missions with no recollection of
memories
she explains her findings to the group
deduces that they need to find a way for
the emergence to not consume innocent
lives or at least put tiana to sleep to
realize this plan they must go to druid
deep in the amazons druid has mixed
feelings upon learning the truth and
initially refuses to help the team
suddenly the deviants ambush them when
icarus is about to tell cersei something
thena goes rogue again while gilgamesh
is desperately fighting the deviants out
powered gilgamesh is killed but luckily
thiena regains consciousness and quickly
runs to him the deviant absorbs
gilgamesh's powers as it did with ayak
cersei plunging into a pool with a
deviant touches it and uses her ability
to transform the deviant into a tree
something she has never done before
they mourn gilgamesh's death and cremate
him in hindu tradition before athena
scatters his ashes into the river the
team decides to seek fasto's help
despite knowing that fastos had given up
on humanity a long time ago a flashback
shows the condition after the 1945
hiroshima atomic bombing when fastos
regretted his decision to help humanity
advance
in the present day fastos lives with his
husband and child in an ordinary house
when icarus and cersei pay him a visit
after hearing the truth fastos deduces
that ayak refused to let him help
humanity advance in a way he intended to
because it will not create enough
population intended to feed tiemen
although initially refusing to join the
plan he finally agrees to help after his
husband convinces him to go
all the assembled eternals then go to
their domo spacecraft buried in
present-day iraq
they find macri already inside and they
begin to discuss strategies to execute
their plan
fastos explains that celestials are
energy generators and imbued eternals
their creations with an infinite amount
of cosmic energy
from the information that deviants are
now able to absorb eternal's energy he
theorizes that he can construct a device
for eternals to absorb their own
energies as well
the unification of the eternals will
create a uni mind providing enough
energy for druid to mind control tiamat
to sleep
macri asks what will be done next to
which cersei replies they can find
humans a new home on another planet
sprite argues that space colonization
could take decades cersei replies again
that the process could be accelerated
with eternal's help
however king kingu is also doubtful of
the plan and asks icarus for his opinion
kingo and sprite think that icarus is
their strongest member so he should be
their leader to which icarus politely
states that ayaka already chose cersei
then he storms away from the room
kingo follows him saying he would have
followed him as he always did but icarus
is unsure of himself
outside he remembers events of six days
ago when he visited a yacht in her cabin
turns out ayak already told him about
the emergence that they only had seven
days left and needed to assemble the
others
however ayak was unsure that the people
of this planet deserve to die for a
celestial's birth to which icarus
disagrees
he was really shocked to know that ayak
would plan to stop the emergence ayak
explained that she saw the people of
earth live their life and changed her
perception of harishem's plan including
when they succeeded in bringing back
half of the population erased by thanos
five years ago icarus took ayat to
alaska where they discovered newly
awakened deviants he told her that he
never doubted his purpose even though he
kept ayok's secrets from the others for
centuries he pushed her from the cliff
and watched as she was killed by the
deviants then took her body back to her
cabin
back to the present day cersei finds
icarus and approaches him they embrace
each other again and walk back to the
domo when cersei is surprised by a pulse
of energy from her sphere
she realizes that the emergence has
begun
fastus has still not figured a way to
construct the uni mind then asks mackery
to find the point of emergence to
cersei's surprise icarus suits up then
he explains that he would not let anyone
disturb the emergence even if it means
he must kill his fellow eternals he
attacks fasto's work then cersei
explains to the group that icarus knew
about the emergence all along
however she is curious why ayoke did not
choose icarus to replace her
druid being a mind reader exclaims that
icarus killed ayak icarus tells the rest
of the team that they will not succeed
against him then prepares to leave just
as sprite announces she will join him
they leave to the point of emergence the
group is still in shock then kingo also
leaves as he believes they should not
turn against the celestials and does not
want to fight icarus
druid tells them that they need to have
a backup plan fastos learns that cersei
was able to turn a deviant into a tree
even though she is still unsure how she
did it she also denies the idea that she
can do the same to a celestial athena
approaches her and convinces her of her
leadership position and her ability then
fastos runs to her to ask about the
sphere inside of her he theorizes that
he can repurpose that sphere to serve
their plan
he succeeds then the group suit up and
go to the point of emergence which is an
island in the middle of the indian ocean
icarus and sprite already on the island
watch the volcanic eruption as they see
the domo approaching they plan to keep
the other eternals busy so they would
not disturb the emergence icarus attacks
the domo encountering fina inside
druid macri and cersei are preparing to
begin the uni mind on the beach
however just when he can put tiana to
sleep icarus notices it and attacks
druid makari evacuates fastos thena and
cersei then brutally attacks icarus
cersei realizes she now has to deal with
transforming tiamat as druid cannot put
him to sleep anymore
she goes to the mountain but is stabbed
by sprite luckily sprite is knocked
unconscious by droog so cersei can
continue her plan
fastos with the help of his devices
trapsicurus down
however the deviant comes to aid icarus
and encounters thena almost killing and
absorbing her powers when theena snaps
back into reality and beheads him when
tiamet is emerging cersei turns him into
marble stone but icarus escapes
when he is about to kill her he cannot
bring himself to do it so she continues
with her plan
the unimine finally forms to which
icarus and sprite are also linked with
that power cersei can completely turn
tiamet into stone she goes back to the
group embraced by macri and the others
however icarus leaves flying to the sun
sprite wants to transform into a normal
human able to grow up and die to which
cersei agrees to do
the group separates again with cersei
fastos sprite and kingo remaining on
earth while druid macri and then aboard
the domo in search of other eternals
sprite goes to school while cersei
spends time again with dane however she
is suddenly unconscious and taken away
from earth by irishm
he takes fast dose and kingo as well and
plans to judge them for their act of
killing and eternal and sparing life on
earth
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching